請問我要從哪出去?
你了解意思嗎?所以說你這附比較特殊的是說
以我得到的訊息是全退
第一個全退叫做口語化
但是一來講我們兩件事
上次有說的是一個叫圖面
第二個是我們應該是最佳檢的部分
然後而且重點是我們的迴路有空調
那我想問一下那空調幹管的線有留嗎
不是 這就是一個很大的那個就是說
第一個 圖面上 簽那個圖說
也沒有空調的點
你們空調不是大腦已經溢射在空調的一個地方嗎
不是我想配哪就配哪不是不是 不是就像你這件事比較特殊的說我講實在話我也是第一次特別裡面全會啊啊當然我們講實在話我不曉得因為當下你們設計師有什麼想法我們真的也不知道我請問一下因為我們現在討論這一些那我這樣子講 接下來等一下怎麼進行 我們參考看看
就是我們是不是可以看一下我們的圖縮跟現場有什麼不符 那你們有說提到的是這五個地方目前沒有做
那我們可不可以就圖縮的部分也check一下 還有什麼沒有做到,然後再來另外一個部分是我們如果就原始的圖面跟現在的追加簡單,這個也是我們可以坐下來對一下,就是那像我們剛才說,我們業主的認知是插座退了,回路沒有退,那這一些的話,這個因為如果這樣子的話,理論上應該是要退回路的費用,我這樣說就知道因為他在做什麼的 因為我要跟他講一下 因為他是說要對單子對圖
我要先說明一下業主他的問題點就是說你這邊是寫插座
可是他們疑問說 那我的回路應該在上面
像我們報價就是一個回路 可能這個回路吃五個插座 是不是這樣罷了 對嗎?
那我等一下 我補充一個很大的問題齁
因為當初我知道在課片的時候是不是這樣罷了 對嗎?那我等一下 我補充一個很大的問題
因為當初我知道在課片的時候
並沒有給我們這裡面原本你們預計是多少的費用讓我們去做散減項
原本的退價只有十幾萬
那這最後退到二十幾萬是我們自己算出來的
你們也任列有這些空間有這些數量才扣這些追檢
所以其實在我們業主方來講要自立自強
然後你們一開始的推價數量也不足 也是要由我們提供出來
所以不是說你把完整的水電的單價讓我去三項 我不知道你有幾回
我不知道東西有什麼 甚至連踢腳裡面的項目也沒有
我們是依你們的 客變扣款的單價去算數量的
這部分建商完全沒有幫忙 一開始只有扣款的單價去算數量的這部分建商完全沒有幫忙
一開始只有扣十幾萬 我們算完扣的數量不止
那一定是經過建商在認定我們算的數量
這核實是真的 才會扣到這些錢
那這是由我們算的 那最後你沒有提供你們全部的東西
現在說我們簽完客變是我們的問題
我覺得這太牽強了而且我們如果再買這些東西前提,我們該配的管也沒有配到。
我覺得這不是討論事情的重點。
我知道,但是我必須說,剛才的說法我先把這個東西也沒有做到,這是我們現在非常大的面跟最終的圖面來判斷說理論上室內應該有幾個迴路,如果說迴路沒有退掉的話,就是這個是我們這邊目前這樣子認為,那這個這樣子就是等於是說要補多少迴路,是對你們也認同的應該要做的部分他現在是不是少了五個空管跟四萬級電源是就我們認為如果本來牆面或者是室內短可能不管是走地板